gonna be my guy bressler from mit and
take it away
guy great thanks ryan thanks to all the
organizers for the invitation
uh really enjoyed the workshop so far so
uh the goal of this talk
is to prevent us is to present a set of
results based on average case reductions
which provide a complementary and
powerful perspective
towards understanding statistical
computational gaps
and and that's sort of as compared to
studying restricted
classes of algorithms which has been
what the majority of the
talks have been about so despite this
being a different perspective
we'll see that reductions can also
sort of raise the stakes for studying
specific problems
and the specific problem here is going
to be secret leakage planted clique
and it's going to raise the stakes for
setting this problem under restricted
cost of algorithms
so there's you know very much
complementary perspectives that kind of
can help one another so this is joint
work with matt brennan he's a student at
mit
and this project would not have been
remotely
the same without him and he's even in
the audience
already so i guess one other note
the papers on archive please go have a
look at it if there's
uh stuff in the talk that you wanna
learn more about
okay so i'm gonna go through the intro
it's gonna be kind of a basic intro
i'm gonna go through it very quickly the
reason being that there are various
notions that i sort of need to emphasize
and hopefully if i go through it at an
appropriate pace there will be time left
over for more technical content in the
second half
okay so the sorts of problems that we're
interested in
are estimating some signal and noise
all of the talks virtually have been
either this or some optimization variant
and one thing that's worth mentioning is
that these sorts of high dimensional
stats problems typically have a bunch of
parameters dimension
for some sort of structure parameter for
example sparsity
number of samples signal strength
parameter possibly others in addition to
these
now the basic question you might ask and
that we've all been asking is well how
much data do you actually need
so if we're going to look at an example
we might look at the spiked covariance
model
and consider tuple of parameters and
you'd want to know well
can i solve this for a given tuple of
parameters so to answer the sorts of
question
we're going to view as the solution a
feasibility diagram
the diagram is a plot that
for any point on this on this uh
on this plane here we have some sparsity
that's given by alpha
in other words k is n to the alpha
that's the sparsity of the signal
on the vertical axis we have beta as
beta gets bigger
theta is n to the minus beta and the
signal gets weaker and so
any point here if we fix d is equal to n
which i wrote up there
we have a given tuple of parameters you
might ask is this feasible or not
the information theoretic question was
answered by bert and regulate
and they weren't entirely satisfied as
none of us are
because efficient algorithms can't
actually achieve the information
theoretic threshold as far as we know
so they sought to explain this proved a
lower bound based on planet clique
hypothesis then a bunch of other people
both you'll see chronologically before
and after
worked very hard both on the algorithmic
side and the lower bound side to
complete this feasibility diagram
so on one hand this is great we have a
good understanding of what's happening
with sparse pca in terms of feasibility
computationally and information
theoretically
just to be extra clear here easy here
means polynomial time
typically very fast hard means feasible
in principle but computationally hard
impossible means
straight up and possible you can't do it
even with
you know arbitrary runtimes
okay so yeah so this is good on the one
hand but it's also troubling because
it's a huge amount of work by a ton of
people
to understand this one problem and we
have a big variety of problems each of
these problems has its own peculiar
structures some of these are graph
matching problems graph clustering
problems tensor problems
cryo-em regression virtually every
problem we care about
has this sort of easy hard impossible
phase diagram and it would be
really really nice to have some sort of
unified understanding
of what's causing the hardness where is
this hardness and so forth
so in particular we might ask well what
would it even mean
to say that a set of problems each have
their hard regime
for the very same reason okay and some
other motivation for this whole talk
and this whole work is that an extremely
satisfying answer
would be that there's some source
problem or root
problem for instance planet clique that
reduces to all of these
in particular reduces to all of these in
each of their hard regimes
and that fully would then explain why
each of those is hard in the hard regime
because
there is in some sense an instance of
planet clique living inside of it
and so that's the reductions approach
that i'll
explain in a little more detail but
that's that's sort of the high level is
that it really gives a sort of unified
picture
when one is able to produce such a
reduction
okay so a few broad objectives just to
emphasize
and this is what we're all trying to do
in this workshop is
predict computational data limits for
efficient algorithms and give evidence
for where that limit is
we want to find optimal algorithms and
optimality is under
some sort of strong evidence for the
lower bound that that one cannot improve
upon what these algorithms are doing
we want to understand the basic
phenomena what's going on why is this
problem hard
and if we might be very ambitious and
dream a bit
then we might hope to understand
relationships between these problems
and a sort of pipe dream would be to say
that any problem under the sun that you
would care about
is in some sense the same problem and
this
you know you would look to complexity
theory and look at big complexity
classes like np complete
problems as inspiration for that
so what are we going to do in this talk
well i'm going to spend a little bit of
time
motivating in a little bit of detail and
explaining the average case reductions
approach
and what we get out of it and then we're
going to obtain a unified understanding
for the computational phase diagrams for
a variety of problems
via a generalization and a planting
clique that's called secret leakage
plank leak there's an asterisk here
which is that
this is quite a short talk and there's
only going to be time to present
one of many reductions that are in the
paper i'll only present
one in some detail
okay so average case reductions
this the notion of average case
reduction the notion of reduction that's
appropriate for us that we use is
average case reduction
in total variation and so the idea here
is that you start with some problem
here is p and we're going to consider
hypothesis testing problems
in this talk and most of what i say will
apply also to estimation problems
but for the details on that you can look
in the paper
but yeah for the purposes of talk
hypothesis testing problems we have a
hypothesis testing problem there's one
distribution that's a null distribution
p sub h zero there's another
distribution that's the alternative
distribution p sub h1
and you have also a problem of interest
that's p
prime and what you want is a polynomial
time algorithm
a that takes as input
an instance and you don't know the
algorithm doesn't know whether it's the
null or the alternative h0h1
and it produces the corresponding output
and that's what this arrow denotes is
that it maps to the corresponding output
in distribution and the error here
little of one is an error in the total
variation distance
between the desired target and the
actual output of the algorithm
so why is this good well it's good
because if somebody
claims to have some algorithm a prime
that solves the hypothesis testing
problem
p prime well then
you would have a solution to the
original problem to see that
suppose that somebody flips a coin
to then produce a sample either from h0
or h1
you don't need to know which one it is
because the algorithm in either case
maps to the correct
output distribution and then you have a
genuine instance of the desired p-prime
problem
algorithm a prime solves it because it
is supposed to solve the p-prime problem
and you've then solved the original
problem so a little bit more formally
the composition of the reduction and the
algorithm a prime
is actually an algorithm for the
original problem and you can convince
yourself also that its run time is
basically that of a prime
plus that of the reduction
all right so reductions are quite
effective
in reasoning about computational
complexity that's why they're the bread
and butter of complexity theory
and for our purposes there are a few
things that i want to emphasize one is
that
if the reduction itself is very
efficient let's say linear time
then reductions transfer fine grained
run times
both above and below polynomial time a
second point is that
if you want to understand the complexity
of the target problem
it's suffices to consider the root
problem
for the purpose of showing hardness what
do i mean by this well
if you have hardness based on some
conjecture
for that some restricted class of
algorithms is optimal for instance
low degree likelihood ratio or
statistical query algorithms or whatever
and under a belief that those
that class of algorithm is optimal one
concludes that the root problem
is hard that hardness is immediately
transferred
to the target problem
okay so that's nice and if that root
problem
reduces too many target problems then
one really only needed to show hardness
for the restricted class of algorithms
for that one root problem and this is
all
of course under the assumption that one
cares about
efficiency or lack of existence or lack
of existence of an efficient algorithm
for the target problem there is sort of
a nitpicky point here which
is important which is that
if for instance we take low degree
polynomials as our class of algorithms
the reduction
might not be a low degree polynomial
itself and so one doesn't necessarily
immediately conclude that the target
problem uh
is hard for low degree polynomials but
if one takes
low degree polynomials you know their
failure as evidence for
there being no polytom algorithm one
transfers the existence of or
non-existence of poly-time algorithms
okay good so in light of this the
reductions
are future-proof against new and
stronger class of algorithms because if
someone comes up with something better
then it suffices to consider the root
problem and study that in depth
for the new class of algorithms so this
is motivation for reductions
and uh given all this we're you know
we're very motivated to to try to
find reductions and we in this paper
that i'm discussing we obtain the
following web of reductions
with secret leakage planet clique up
here at the root
and then propagating out to all the
problems that are here on the slide
okay so a few quick remarks about this
web
the first is that the first layer here i
guess i have this laser pointer so the
first layer here k-part-type planet
clique bipartite planetary k-part
bipartite planet click and capartite
hypergraph lanocleak
you could just assume something about
each of these
and use those as your hardness
assumptions
it turns out that k-partite hypergraph
planet leak
is actually a stronger hardness assuming
that that problem is hard in a certain
regime
implies hardness for the rest of them
and so if you would like you could
assume that just this one problem is
hard
secret leakage planet clique is a
unified way of
viewing all of these problems and
potentially many others
all right so i'm going to describe what
is secret leakage planet clique
and then we'll go on to the reduction
technique and an application of it
that that's the one that we chose to
highlight in this talk
okay so if i'm going to describe secret
leakage planet clique i'd better quickly
describe planet clique the the
original ordinary planet clique so what
is it well one starts with an air dish
or any random graph let's say g in half
and then uniformly at random plants a
cake leak a fully connected
subset of size k of course
one doesn't know the identity of the
vertices and they're not colored red
and the task is to recover
those vertices that are in the clique or
the hypothesis testing variant would be
to decide
was a clique even planted in the first
place
okay so in the hypothesis testing
variant we have h0 is pure noise
h1 there's a clique in there so what's
known
well if the size of the clique that you
put in there is bigger than 2 log
n then it's going to be bigger than the
size of the biggest
naturally occurring clique in a random
graph
and so one can detect presence of the
clique just by searching over all
subsets
clearly that's not efficient if one is
restricted to polynomial time
then all of the known algorithms require
constant times root n and for example
spectral algorithm
succeeds in that regime despite
decades of effort this hasn't been
improved upon and so it's conjectured to
be computationally hard if the size of
the clique
is smaller than square root of n
okay and this is the plenticle
conjectures that indeed it's hard
all right so i'll mention here that
there's been work by
a large variety of folks including
people in this workshop
on understanding why is planted clique
seemingly hard in this regime
of k's smaller than root n
okay just one note i'm often asked what
is this average case
why do you talk about average case
probably everybody here knows this but
just to
just in case average case just means
that the input to the problem is drawn
from a distribution so we talk about
average case reductions we talk about
mapping distributions
all right so most of the average case
reductions start from planet clique
and map to a problem of the following
form sparse submatrix
plus independent noise if you look at
this if you squint your eyes
then this doesn't look so different from
from the starting assumption
of planet clique itself and there are
many problems with very different
structures
and so one would hope to map also to
those other problems
yet there's never there's little
evidence that
one can actually do this using
reductions so that was our
primary motivation we wanted to know
well can you actually map to this huge
variety of problems with different
structures that are quite different from
sparse submatrix plus noise
using average case reductions and our
answer
is yes you can but planet clique does
not seem
like the right starting point instead
it turns out to be useful to consider
slight variance or generalizations of
planted clique
so here's one example of such a variant
of planet clique
so instead of the clique being uniform
at random over all
n choose k subsets of size k we're going
to
imagine that the vertices are in k
different parts
and the clique is guaranteed to have one
vertex from
each part so if you think about this for
a bit
the entropy or the total number of
possible cliques
is essentially the same as it is in the
ordinary planet clique we haven't
significantly constrained its position
it doesn't help that much to find it
and so we conjecture that this remains
hard
for cliques up to size root n
but at the same time there is a little
bit of information about the clique you
know for instance that
if the the partition of the vertices um
has one through
n over k as the first partition you know
that you can't have two click vertices
in that first part so there is a little
bit of information
so that's one example of the sort of
starting problem that we consider
there are several others bipartite
versions
k part bipartite versions k part type
hyper graph versions
but i won't define carefully but they're
a similar flavor
and all of these can be captured in a
single general setup
which we call secret leakage planet
clique so what is this problem
well take rho to be a distribution on k
subsets of the vertices
and let the g rho
secret leakage distribution be
obtained by starting with an air
distribution random graph with edge
probability half
select a subset s according to
distribution row
and then plan to k click on that subset
so it's just like planet clique except
for the distribution over the cliques
is row instead of uniform
now the task is to detect presence of
the clique and so
it's a hypothesis testing problem you
could of course ask also the estimation
problem
it's not hard to check that each of the
example
problems that i defined a moment ago are
actually instances
of secret leakage planted with
appropriately chosen
row with a properly chosen distribution
over the cliques
all right so when is this generalized
planning clique or secret leakage planet
clique problem hard
the pc row conjecture is that if you
consider
two independent samples s and s prime
from row
so you are taking two independent
cliques and one considers the
probability mass function
of the overlap of the intersection of
these two sets
then if that decays at some rate
then the problem is computationally hard
then there is no polynomial time
algorithm
solving the problem so where did this
come from
well this comes from the low degree
likelihood ratio
calculation for this problem and it's
also supported by the statistical query
framework
and uh we very much invite any of you
who have
your favorite class of algorithms to
study this problem and
um hopefully we can get insight into it
all right so that's secret leakage
planted clique
in the remaining time i'm going to talk
about an example reduction technique
that we call bernoulli rotations
and i'll show how it's applied
to reduce to a single problem
and jump right in there's not a whole
lot of time left
okay so bernoulli rotation so before i
talk about bernoulli rotations it turns
out actually that we need to talk about
changes of measure you might want to
change
the measure of the distribution of
entries in a matrix for example if you
want to map from planet clique to by
clustering
this is the problem that subarrata
talked about earlier this morning
so here we have bernoulli's getting
mapped to gaussians
now the simplest way to map this entire
matrix is to map
each entry individually and um
this sort of map was what mon wu did in
their paper and by clustering in 2014
and
it was also developed in a paper of
hayaku and shu
um and then further generalized uh into
a form that we called reduction kernels
and a couple of papers over the last few
years
okay so what is it that we want we want
a random mapping
rk rejection kernel that takes this
input or random variable
and concretely it's going to be either
zero or one but it's
coming from some distribution so that if
it had input that was distributed
bernoulli half
then the output is very close in total
variation to standard gaussian
and if the input's one then it's very
close in distribution
in in total variation to gaussian with
mu and mu
and variance one so how would you
construct such a mapping
it turns out it's actually not that hard
so the first case is
immediate if the input is one well then
you have to just produce an
output sample that's gaussian with mean
mu
what do you do if the input is zero well
we know what we want the in the the
output to be if the input is bernoulli
half
so you can solve a system of linear
equations and conclude that if the
input is zero you would like to produce
a sample that has density
2 phi 0 minus v1 where p0 and v1 are the
appropriate gaussians
and then you can check that the
bernoulli half gives rise to the
half-half mixture of the one and the
zero case and indeed that's v0 that's
the distribution we wanted
there's a problem here here
if you think about it for a bit you see
that 2 phi 0 minus v1
is not necessarily a valid density
because it takes negative values
so this is an annoyance and this
annoyance is overcome
by truncating the density to the
positive part it amounts to conditioning
in a certain
range and that induces a small error in
total variation distance and so that's
why this
this mapping is approximate okay so what
have we accomplished what we've
taken as input of bernoulli that's
either bernoulli half or bernoulli one
and we've produced his output
uh gaussian that's either mean zero or
mean
that was a change of measure it's
largely
you could argue an aesthetic
consideration
but it turns out that this change of
measure is also useful
for changing the structure of the
planted signal and that's where
bernoulli rotations come into the
picture
so what is the goal of bernoulli
rotations the the setup is as follows
you have a vector
of iid bernoulli have random variables
but there is a single position i that's
been fixed to one
okay so you could think of this as some
sort of planted vector
now what we want to output is a gaussian
vector with independent entries
and the mean vector a sub i so i
corresponds to the bit that was fixed to
one
and we have n such possible mean vectors
corresponding to each possible location
of the fixed bit
formally the planted bernoulli
distribution
gets mapped to the appropriate gaussian
this tau attenuation is essentially a
log factor
polylog factor and there's also this
extra factor here that's the largest
singular value
of the matrix formed by these a vectors
and so if you don't want to have this
mean being very close to zero then
one should not have too big of a
singular value
so how does one obtain this sort of
mapping i'll describe that in a second
worth mentioning that the whole magic in
applications here is going to be
choosing the ais in a smart way
and the ais are often going to be a
flattening of some matrix or tensor
all right so here's the bernoulli
rotational algorithm we start
as input this planted bernoulli vector
bernoulli halves with unknown planted
ith bit equal to one
we form b prime which is a gaussian
version by applying the gaussian
rejection kernels
we then sample a vector u that's
isotropic gaussian
in n dimensions and then we form this
vector x
that's given by this superposition of
these two
quantities and
let's parse this and see what those
quantities each actually are
so first let's go back to v prime well v
prime is
a gaussian with isotropic covariance and
sort of mean vector that's the standard
basis
in the i coordinate of course rescaled a
bit
and so then if you hit this vector by
matrix
a then that picks out the appropriate
column so this first term
is the correct mean that we're hoping
for of course now we've screwed up the
covariance of this
of this matrix a v prime has a not the
correct isotropic covariance
so the second term here corrects the
covariance and it cancels the induced
correlations
that the first part caused and so this
indeed
does what we want it to all right so in
the
just really quickly i'm going to show
how this
bernoulli rotations sort of gadget
is actually used for a genuine problem
of interest
in the statistics community to change
the structure meaningfully and map
precisely in total variation to robust
sparse mean estimation
i might go a couple minutes over i'm
sorry about that
okay so what's the problem uh that we're
interested in well
i'll talk about sparse main estimation
first it's the problem
of the hypothesis testing variant would
be deciding between isotropic gaussian
and the same thing but with
a small mean shift where now tau is some
k-sparse
unit vector and then its l2 norm is this
epsilon factor in front
so let's sparse mean estimation there's
no information computation gap
the second problem is robust sparse mean
estimation and here
this is under huber's contamination
model of robustness so now
there is uh epsilon one minus epsilon
mixture and you could think of it
as an epsilon fraction of the samples
are contaminated by some outlier
distribution
the outlier and now there is
conjecture to be a statistical
computational gap uh this has been made
rigorous
in the statistical query framework by
nicholas kane and stewart
and the gap is a k versus k squared gap
okay so this is the problem that we want
to reduce to
and we're going to consider a special
case here which is just choosing a
particular outlier distribution
and the cartoon of how the data matrix
looks like
is a d by n matrix with a block here
that's this
blue and red and the blue corresponds to
the correct mean
and the red corresponds to these outlier
means
so here's how the reduction looks it's
it's actually very simple now that we
have everything set up
we start with an instance of k part
bipartite
pc and so there are ones in each
appropriately sized block here
we apply bernoulli rotations to each of
these
vectors individually we get a gaussian
with appropriate mean
where this mean is a column in some
matrix
or here let's say a row and some matrix
one does this to all of these sub
vectors
within the starting matrix that was this
bipartite planetary adjacency matrix
and one gets the following which is a
gaussian matrix now with all of these
shifted means
we compare this to our cartoon and we
can see that we would
like one of these aj vectors
to just have two values either blue
or red and so that gives us our design
criterion
tells us sort of what we want out of
these these vectors
and it turns out that one can indeed
construct
the ai vectors um
[Music]
and this construction that's described
here comes from the incidence geometry
of points and hyperplanes
um in uh in vector spaces over finite
fields
f r to the t and it turns out to
exactly satisfy the criterion so that
this cartoon that we had of a bus versus
person estimation
is actually what when maps do
okay so this is just one reduction to
one problem that i described
there are a bunch of other reductions to
a bunch of other problems
in the the negative several minutes i'll
just say in 10 seconds that
here's sort of a schematic of the the
reduction to mixtures of sparse linear
aggressions which is much more
complicated and combines
a number of such reduction gadgets
to then reduce to mixtures of sparse
linear regressions from k
part diet from k-part bipartite planet
clique
and so one of the exciting things i
think with this approach is that each of
the reduction gadgets
can be applied hopefully to many other
problems in the future
in new and interesting ways
awesome so to conclude there's a new
unifying problem that i think
deserves more study secret leakage
planet clique
we reduce to a number of different
problems with
very different structures and there's a
great deal left to do
and we're very excited about this
direction so thanks very much
thanks skye
uh we do have time for questions
maybe i can have something go ahead uh
so like how complicated are finally the
secret leakage that you're using like
you use the k partite
like uh you use the hyper graph like i
don't know like how complicated does it
get
like since you have all these like
generally yeah exactly that's a great
question
i mean we just use these four in in the
paper so
in the uh i mean i guess the whole web
is here so
we only use the four that are appearing
here and actually the
the k-part hyper graph pc is stronger
than any of the others so you could just
use that one
for the purpose of the reductions that
we carry out
um the unification i think is meaningful
and
yeah we we sort of just viewed it as a
way to kind of coherently address all of
them and produce a single conjecture
thanks again
yeah you made the point about um run
times transferring in a
fine-grained way uh one one thing about
planet cleak reductions is
that at least in the vanilla planet leak
they don't typically give you lower
bounds of the kind that like ilius was
talking about just before
this you know a sub-exponential type of
lower bounds can you hope to get that
from
these stronger planetary variants
great question yeah so i think it
depends
i think that probably the the right
answer would be that
one wouldn't want to consider these
particular variants of planet clique one
would want to consider
constrained variants of planet dense
subgraph so planet and subgraph has very
similar behavior in terms of
sub-exponential time algorithms and so
forth as as you know i guess
um and so all of these reductions
actually work starting from
those problems okay cool thanks
do you think there's hope to get a
reduction to ksat
uh like maybe refutation just about the
satisfaction threshold
this is this sounds very hard but um
i i i personally haven't particularly
thought about it it's hard to know i
mean
i i think that it's hard to know ahead
of time
whether there's going to be a reduction
to any particular given problem i mean
i should say that a priori i didn't
think that we could reduce
any of these problems and matt proved me
wrong
um so yeah so so i mean i don't know if
that answers your question but
like somehow i mean it does require i
think sort of a lot of thought to even
get a sense for can one reduce to a
given problem when the structures are so
different
i see i saw centerpiece day on the slide
so i was hopeful maybe that you had
thought about it but
absolutely yeah sorry to be fair we
thought about it maybe matt can answer
but but we did think about it uh
there are some peculiarities here that
we don't know how to overcome that are
specifically with the sparsity there
yeah so like for example yeah like if
you replace tensor pca with 3xor you'd
imagine like algorithmically it's kind
of the same but for reductions it seems
like it's a little nastier
because um the fact that you have like
sparse noise
um rather than like dense noise as you
have intensive pca seems to make a
difference for reductions
so um at the moment yeah like a lot of
techniques break
going to something like uh like these
random csps
but um like a prior we don't have any
like real
technical like obstruction that we're
able to prove
against these sort of reductions so we
don't know at the moment
yeah maybe just to add reductions to
sparse things or something that we don't
understand very well there are also some
reductions here in the upper left
to variants of stochastic block models
but all of those are in
dense settings
uh we have a question from ashwin ashwin
can you uh speak up
right now yeah can you hear me yep okay
perfect
um so thanks guys just a quick question
maybe you already addressed this in
some form or another but is there some
sense in which there are reductions
within
secret leakage like there are some
priors that imply hardness for other
players
or you know is this entire ensemble of
assumptions that you stated somehow
incomparable
no i mean that's a it's a perfect
question yeah so the the the k-part
hyper graph planet clique would be one
particular variant that's a stronger
um assumption than the other three that
are there and there is a reduction
from k-part hypergraph planet gleek to
the other three
so for our purposes is that a more
generalized version of this
i don't know because i mean that's a
good question
i mean i think it would just depend in
the you know in the context whether
something would make whether it would
make sense to assume a more general
version we haven't we haven't needed to
yet so i
don't know if we've been motivated to
think in that direction but it's a good
question
yeah what's the sort of strongest
concrete single assumption
uh as far as i know this is the one so
far is this hypergraph
variant
yeah one uh like one comment on that
like yeah guys totally right like i
don't know if there's any sort of
general principle
that we're aware of um in fact like at
the moment with
within reductions like within secret
leakage like the ones from k-part
hypergraph planning fleet to these other
three are all kind of trivial so we
don't really have any
examples of non-trivial reductions
within secret leakage
uh one kind of technical obstruction to
this is it's even
uh not known how to reduce from an
instance of planet clique with like
planet clique size k and uh graph size n
um an edge density half oh yeah sorry
engine see like a quarter for example to
to the corresponding version with the
edge density half so
like like to some extent reducing within
secret leakage would have to capture
some of these things because if for
example
one example of secret leakage would be
you just pair up all the vertices
and uh and at that point you can just
take the end of all the edges within
every
um like within every like bipartite
graph of size two by two
and then that will reduce the edge
density from half to like one over
like one yeah one over like two to the
six or something
and so in that case uh like you would
have to be capturing these reductions
that we don't
know of so like i guess the short answer
is that
there aren't really any known
non-trivial reductions within secret
leakage yet
thanks
um guy maybe i can ask him a slightly
naive question
so please that's great yeah so maybe
so i was i was intrigued because uh you
mentioned this sort of
robust sparse mean estimation question
right and and the
the version without this uber
contamination part doesn't have any
information computation gap right but on
the other hand
i see in your reductions you have tons
of problems where you don't need this
robustness kind of thing right
so is there any sort of intrinsic reason
why in this particular problem or you
know you need this sort of
uber contamination part whereas in
others you don't need it
i guess i don't know
i i think one can get some intuition
about your question
from thinking about what what would how
like how could you reduce to
a non-robust version it turns out that
those negative entries
are are necessary in the matrix
so that the matrix has sort of the
desired properties
otherwise you you sort of get a vacuous
reduction
kind of necessarily from the particular
gadget so i think one can look at it and
see how it fails but
yeah so actually um yes i was wondering
um whether there's any reduction based
hardness evidence for
um say block model under the ks
threshold
yeah so so uh this there there is so the
uh imbalanced two sbm here um
that's kind of an upper left of this web
you could think of as the
the task of recovering a first community
out of k
where the rest are under a sort of mean
field model that they're averaged over
and um and this is in the dense regime
then
then the uh the ks threshold is
supported by
a reduction from k-part planet clique
cool okay
is k larger than constant there so is
that is that first community
kind of you know is it little o of n the
same way that planted cliques are
yes yeah it's it's a k is scaling yeah
and then siddhant's question was
uh what if you want to do something for
sparse graphs you said this is in the
dense regime
right so that's that is a great question
and i think
if one figured out how to do that it
would be great we don't know how
um but it certainly is i mean connects
also to what matt was saying before and
the question with that
with 3xor i mean i think we're just at
the moment limited to
dense things and that's maybe one
conceptual way to see that is that this
bernoulli
rotations goes through gassings
and maybe there's some way to avoid that
and to get to sparse things but
we've thought about it and we don't we
don't know how to do it at this point
thank you just a further comment on
chris's question
so like uh the regime of k and the this
dense
stochastic block model um result is
it's it's not like exactly the same as
planning click like k is allowed to be
much larger than root n like k
can be like n to the one minus epsilon
for arbitrarily small epsilon
um just the only issue is that our lower
bounds are coarse grained up to
like factors of root log n in like all
thresholds and signal parameters
so if you went to a regime where k was
scaling linearly with n
then um like our reduction would be too
coarse-grained to capture like
for example like constant gap uh
statistical computational trade-offs
okay let's okay sorry but at the moment
it seems hard
and i mean i i've asked guy about this
before and i i think this is great work
um so i'm not trying to be negative but
it seems hard to
see how one could fit like the k equals
five
you know the five community block model
into this framework where
you know each community has size n over
five
absolutely yeah that's that's absolutely
a great point and i think i think it's
uh
perhaps the primary weakness of of the
reductions approach
in general is because one has to inject
a little bit of noise and carrying out
these reductions
inevitably when one loses small factors
and uh yeah it seems hopeless to obtain
that sort of precise
result okay yeah maybe
sorry yeah we should probably move on to
the next talk so
uh maybe we can hold the rest of our
questions for chat or you talk to guy
afterwards so let's thank him again
and